[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sitôt que le printemps apparaît sous les
cieux dans les cerveaux il germe une
folie par un charme puissant doux et
mystérieux ces messieurs jeunes ou vieux
trouvent toutes les femmes jolies et sur
les avenus et sur les boulevards on
entend ces mots répéter de toutes parts
le printemps chante dans les buissons
saisons charmantes des floraisons
arboront la fleur et lesé gambes sur les
habis sur les vestant à jolie femme de
l'œil de la dent un pied ski et l'autre
aussi la plus les deux paraî
charmante le printemp
chanteante
alors que les amants s'en rontent au
rendez-vous de vieux en qui la vie mis
sa
sagesse devant la porte assis comme de
bons époux d'un œil dou point jaloux
regarde folater la jeunesse et c'est de
bon vieux percl cassé chevrotte ta ce
qui passe temp laassé
le printemps chante dans les buissons
tout vousous en chante fille garçons
quant à nous notre voix
tremblante
à ces dernières
chansons allez enfants embrassez-vous
dans la forêt prochaine hélas ça vous
prendra avant que ça nous
[Musique]
reprenne le
Prin
[Applaudissements]